stabilizing the financial markets and  preventing systemic risks that threaten  the economy  such is the mission of the three  European Supervisory authorities chairs  were grilled by MEP s I personally have  a very positive impression of the work  they have been doing they have received  a very strong and challenging mandate in  difficult times and so it's up to us the  Parliament representatives of the  citizens to follow very closely what are  the elements on which the mandate  eventually has got to be changed or  adapted or if everything is going  smoothly  seriously mr. Schmidt in chefs that  biopsy spare in our ocean the in-video  hardened for any English won't even lean  on the stratum it in your turn  traders bonuses the insurance sector  unlisted real estate products and banks  stress tests with some of the topics  that came up in 2016 European Parliament  will publish a report on the activities  of the Financial Supervision bodies  you